Oh
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Joe G he's the meme
Lord behind YouTube cult heroes filthy
Frank and pink guy his second
full-length project pink season soared
to the top of the iTunes charts earlier
this year and good news there's more new
music on the way Joe G welcome to the
show thank you thank you for having me
this is exciting I've always wanted to
be on this this is sick well how are you
with hot food I've never actually tested
myself I've never seen how far I could
go but my guess is my taste levels are
pretty white
[Music]
okay sorry on there oh oh okay so we're
starting here although so I want to
start by talking about filthy Frank and
pink guy naturally what's the biggest
mess you've ever made during a video and
how long did it take to clean up I
bought like $300 worth of chicken hearts
you know I like tiny someone was
throwing chicken hearts at me a bunch of
people and they got behind the fridge
and just like chicken hearts all over
the apartment it took three days to
clean it and then we had to get a maid
and the maid came and the main said no
and we start to pay her too because she
came all the way for it appearance yeah
so the maid couldn't handle it and we
just kind of left it so there's still
chicken hearts in that apartment like
rotting to this day what's the closest
you've ever been to getting your ass
beat in the field back in the day I was
very very rude we were kind of bullying
a guy in an elevator
we cut the footage but that set another
guy in the elevator off you know it
escalated to an intense level like
someone called the cops and stuff have
you ever been arrested doing these
videos funny enough I've been arrested
for everything but that okay I can feel
it but okay I can still go so oftentimes
internet trends seem to come out of
nowhere all the sudden you'll just see
everybody's dumping ice buckets over
their head or planking on the street and
you have unique perspective when it
comes to that for being the person
credited with originating 2013's biggest
Internet dance craze the Harlem shake I
thought the song had like a special
quality to it I had a bunch of costumes
laying around
and three or four friends there when the
drop came like the idea was we were just
gonna kind of stay like almost idle you
know but we were kind of like air
humping and then I uploaded that like it
was literally like overnight everyone
was doing it and it must be bizarre too
when you see Jimmy Fallon and LeBron G
yeah and the rest of America doing
something that was birthed by pink guy
you know like is that kind of mine [ __ ]
yeah no I kind of looked down on them
for that I was like you guys are stupid
why like I mean I'm not bitter about it
I think I think it was a great thing but
I didn't I still don't understand why
people got so hooked on it
[Music]
damn I'm so hungry going in cracking
bones I love it good good so Japanese
food has really taken America by storm
we're in the throes of ramen mania sushi
is everywhere but as someone who's
actually lived in Japan what do you
think of the food that people are
missing out on what do you see is the
next big mainstream crossover tonkatsu
is pretty underrated here still that's
like fried pork cutlet goes well with
rice it goes well with cabbage I see it
here obviously but I think people
specializing in that will be a new thing
soon and then you know I think the
reason that people always focus on these
crazy Japanese things whether it's you
know tentacle porn or weird KitKat
flavors is that it from the outside
looking in a difficult culture to
understand what do you see as the
biggest misconceptions about Japanese
cuisine when you hear people from
America talking about it honestly
honestly I'm not a sushi snob at all
right I just eat [ __ ] fish on Rice's
show you know but the really nice sushi
in New York City to me is the same taste
as like a sushi place at a train station
in Japan what's up with the women on the
train cars oh well that's good there's
so much sexual harassment in Japan it's
crazy no one talks about it I've been
sexually harassed like an old dude will
grope me because everyone's so packed it
hacked in sometimes when a ladies pushed
up against me
I have no choice but to smell her hair
really all right
[Music]
okay I taste the ginger getting hotter
stay it on top of it though little face
but Jodie mm-hmm I have a vision
old man poor sweat so once it gets to a
certain level I'll give it all you can
wedding yeah so for better or worse you
have one of the more emotionally charged
fan bases on the internet and I've heard
you speak before about feeling
suffocated from time to time in your
personal life when you think about the
crazy faces to face or the pranks with
as you put it the very elaborate fans is
there a story that stands out it's
important to have a fan base that is
that and involved in you and I respect
that
thank you but yeah sometimes you know it
gets a little gets a little rowdy in
fact the only time I want to be
approached is when I'm with a girl cuz
it looks cool but then I often get
tweets after that saying oh I saw you
but you were with the girl so I don't
want to bother you and you're like damn
dude bother me yeah make me a little bro
okay now we get in there yeah okay very
cool all right Joe G so we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham we do a deep dive on
our guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context right
what I'll do is I'll show you the
picture and then you can just tell me
the bigger story does that sound good
yep I hope you got the right Instagram
I've like three Oh what about okay she
crashed do it right that's the one they
got sushi trash' ah
first things first everyone thinks
that's fake
after the Harlem shake some some awards
some net awards show flew me out to do
it live Aerosmith had been performed at
whatever wherever the [ __ ] I was doing
that thing at two famous people that are
like older they think this [ __ ] is
amazing
so he came and he was like wow look you
started this that's amazing like can we
see a live you know like yeah yeah all
right
but like break with post Malone yeah
he's like let's meet a rolling loud and
I saw him and I ran up to him I was like
oh it's me
and he looked at me and he didn't
recognize me out of character so he was
like you good like he thought he thought
I was like some crazed fan and I looked
at him like I - I for a couple seconds I
was like post like and this that would
have been the end for me if he had just
like been like I don't know who you are
and then finally his eyes light up and
it he puts two and two together and he
was like [ __ ] like come to my place
after this like let's hang out that
gentleman with the stomach I don't know
man he brought these strippers and they
were they were doing some like not even
stuff that strippers would do a little
off the beaten path yeah yeah like post
was shocked by he was like what the [ __ ]
is this
Oh YouTube Mount Rushmore with max mofo
idubbbz and ty Lopez we were at this
after-party thing and ty Lopez showed up
and obviously Tai Lopez his Tai Lopez
legend he's got a Lamborghini his garage
we were bothering him alone
I felt like a dick but I heard everyone
was asking him to say here my garage so
he was he was already very bothered by
that
why did you blur out your face in the
picture with jenna Marbles and that at
that time she didn't know who I was so
she thought I was a fan I think and then
I met her again and then the tables have
turned
she was the the fan I see you gave me
the baddest one for dirty dicks
wow you're really good with the [ __ ]
spy what if I was bad well you know what
I mean that's true I can't be bad is
there a story behind why you're so good
at this
I'm not really I don't have like any
like hot sauce roots or anything we just
were like celebrity interviews are
boring how do we make them not boring
and our solve for that was hot sauce you
know so I wasn't a hot sauce guy before
I just had to become one quickly you
know so you work alongside hip-hop
artists like rich chigga out of
Indonesia and then Keith ate out of
South Korea and hip hop it's so
regionally driven you know Houston
sounds like Houston New York has a sound
that's all its own how would you
describe the hip-hop movement that's
coming out of these countries in Asia
right now is definitely influenced by
American hip-hop the way they're doing
it I would say it's it's it's it's a
tribute because even if you don't
understand the language you can still
vibe to it you know I mean I don't
understand what the [ __ ] Keith is
saying on his song you know I mean and
I'm like yeah kill it you know do it
yeah do you think Heath you know he's
old thank you
[Music]
all my lips are burning
ah yeah
off rip this one hits right away
this was quite a [ __ ] jump from dirty
dicks dirty dicks was nothing this is a
zombie apocalypse ah I can't wait to try
the next three I I got to make sure I
don't touch my eyes yeah cuz I see that
happen all the time you have to learn
from others in the state exactly
no highs no generals you can I've heard
so many general stories - there are
nightmare horror stories about the
genitals in the hot ones coffee table
book whenever it comes out oh so when we
had ethan klein on the show he called
you the best youtuber of all time mostly
because you've succeeded in spite of
being shunned by the platform yeah do
you take pride in being an outcast you
think that's helped fuel you or do you
feel like you've been treated unfairly
well well for one thing yes I have
inferior unfairly that's that's no doubt
about that I'm not I'm not bitter about
it though I understand that you know it
is a there's a platform you know they
need to keep their [ __ ] clean I like to
do what I like you know make the stuff
that I think is good or that I think is
funny or that I think sounds great you
know if you like it you can intact Wow
if you like it you can tag along if you
don't [ __ ] it you know I mean that's
yeah it's all good
when you look at things that are
embraced by YouTube all your left that's
sort of an arm's distance is there
anything that leaves you scratching your
head I mean it is they have put in an
algorithm that favors long and
persistent
I shot
oh I breathed in and caught it and and
it hit my throat Wow oh now now we're
talking how am i doing so far did I make
it through pretty well here's what I
would say Joji is that you have some
face wet obvious discomfort the beanie
was sort of a questionable decision but
I understand it I'd say this though your
crack and wings open your cleaning wings
you're definitely a fighter I kind of
help out okay I can't touch my eyes I'm
here for the milk go for them I'm here
in the milk there's no shame in that mmm
where's this whole milk it's whole milk
yeah whole milks the best you can close
your eyes and pretend like it's a
milkshake huh okay oh I'll give you a
second yeah yeah yeah yeah take your
time man take your time
[Music]
Wow all right so filthy Frank is the
embodiment of everything vile on the
internet in a commentary on how much
traction you can get by indulging the
worst aspects of human nature yeah as a
master of the art of parody I wonder if
you have insight to other pop cultural
figures that push the boundaries so I'm
going to bounce some people off of you
yeah and you can tell me if they're
postmodern artists if they're geniuses
or if they're just batshit unhinged
people sound good
Kanye West ah he's a he's a I think I
think he's a genius he's he's made too
much music that's so good each album
[ __ ] revolutionized the sound of oh I
got a my it the sound the sound of what
we listen to and he's just got so many
classics on its belt he can do whatever
the [ __ ] he wants you know I'm not gonna
support it but I'll acknowledge that
it's Kanye being Kanye you know he's a
little nuts but who isn't Alex Jones
he seems like a troll I don't think he
believes that the water is making frogs
gay riff-raff I love her frog I love him
so much I was texting him about ideas he
was talking about driving a Atari in the
Safari anaconda Honda like he was like
when he was throwing around ideas and I
was I was all about it he's a great man
shoutouts to riff raff
[Music]
you gotta give me a minute
take your time Joe G take your time him
Oh feel alive
[Music]
Blair's naked
this one hits a little slower but I can
feel it creep that's bad
we're reaching maximum levels here
[Music]
something music side of things you have
such range you know pink guile put out a
project that's just floor-to-ceiling
memes while Joe GU put out project that
our sister site pigeons and planes calls
gorgeous and stunning first things first
what's the difference musically between
pink guy and Joe G well the it's not
even the inside of my mouth it's it's
everything around the lips maybe your
neck behind the ears I've been there oh
I don't want to be limited to just one
form of production sorry hold on box are
up against the ropes yeah
I'm Conor McGregor right now the pink
eye stuff is easier to make and it's
more it's fun to make I was gonna say on
a creative level the Japanese are
probably very different it's very fun
yeah the Joe G music it's fun but I'm
like well to demonstrate that difference
in the outlets what I want to do is give
you some Joe G lyrics and I'll give you
some pink guy lyrics and then you can
sort of decode them for me jay-z knows
that sound good yeah so this first one
is off pink life I don't need a [ __ ]
marketing
I blow my [ __ ] I'm not a [ __ ] block
hunt with a lot of chicks trying to buy
an autobiography up I'm a dick a lot of
other people on the on the internet with
dedicated followings will you know
they're only like like not even like
twenty-two and they're putting out
autobiographies like what have you lived
you know there's a lot of that going on
if sometimes like you'll just see some
24-year old chick who's like maybe
gotten broken up with three or four
times then all of a sudden they think
they're you know Bridget Jones or some
[ __ ] yeah exactly and I'm not I can't I
can't subscribe to that so this next one
is Joe G song yeah you suck Charlie
[Music]
men with with women you know they don't
want it they don't want to be fully tied
down there or they'll say like you know
now's not the right time now's not the
right time it's kind of like that you
know can you be a little bit stronger
and hold on a little bit because you're
an earthly comfort next one the pink guy
this is off meme machine I catch the
means I spread the memes I eat the memes
I said the memes without memes I will
die I don't [ __ ] know what that means
[Music]
and oh this is a hot ones one smokin
ends a legend I'm gonna look this guy up
so this is the last dab we call it the
last dab because the tradition around
here to put a little dab on the last
wing you don't have to if you don't want
to oh I'm a good sport all all I'll do
it
love the napkins stockpile ya know this
like I gotta do this I'm a napkin man
love it playing fast and loose with the
dab that is that's all right Joe G how
you feelin my whole face it it's like
mace yeah it really it really hurts
mm-hmm oh what a run it's been my man
it's been a great run thank you for
having me jouji anytime anytime
fantastic cheers my man
[Music]
I like the mustard mm-hmm yeah whoa whoa
whoa yo I got that on my what's the
thing that jangles in the backyard throw
you've gotten the punching bag huh yeah
I'm so hungry though so as we've covered
today there are many sides of Joji
whether it's music comedy our being a
self-loathing psychopath and a blue
button um do you ever feel like you live
in the shadow of these characters that
you've created like me with the wings is
there ever a fear that fans won't
embrace you outside of those personas
that was a fear for a very long time
you know people on the Internet are mean
I was doing music hand in hand with the
comedy stuff the pink eye music start at
the same time as filthy Frank but I just
didn't know if people would embrace the
the serious stuff I wish I had the
confidence the self-confidence to to
submit to switch earlier because now
it's it's working out pretty well well
I'll tell you this if it's a new chapter
you look reborn when I look in front of
you today Joe gee thank you getting on
top of the wings clearing the board
leaving all the bones out in front so
people know you clean them I love that
move now there's no way we're we're all
there's a trash can oh I'm sorry this is
so rude it's not rude you have to let
them know you have to let them know
where you went sometimes here it is the
red carpet for you this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
big EP coming out
that's the that's the first time I've
said that my let's say that hello hot
ones fans Sean Evans new outro same
message if you like what you saw throw
us a bone maybe please it is dog-eat-dog
here on the YouTube streets hit that
subscribe button
knowing that you subscribed it is
seriously the only thing that gets me
out of bed in the morning
thank you very much hot ones fans I love
you